oh my god no effing way so I guess you
probably figured out why I invited all
of you here will you be my groomsmen
so obviously Steve is gonna be my best
man oh my god I was best man at my
brother's wedding so you need any hot
tips I got you covered bro no man don't
worry about it I got this this max think
he is um who is this oh this is my
cousin Justin the best friends no I
don't know why I'm not the best man
I'm Eugene's cousin I don't know best
surprise
Steven is in way over his head I'm just
gonna get overwhelmed and drop the ball
and when he does I'll be there to scoop
it up we should probably see what the
bridesmaids look like right on it those
arms
let's see what's your relationship
status say oh she doesn't have it I
really hope I find love at this wedding
you know maybe even get married myself
who knows if you don't like this place
you don't have to go yet
come on let's go yeah we'll find
[Music]
it's like a cool Brazilian New Year's I
think it's like a cool Brazilian coke
dealer I mean your butt looks great
nope no no II know you oh that looks
good
[Music]
guys don't don't mess up the suit it's
yeah do you think he's okay for thing
are you ready to get hot for this
wedding I'm ready to get hot for this
wedding let's do it
I have anything gluten in two months
yeah I'm on a strict liquid diet
I think free cold showers a day because
they're shivering burns calories wait
our outfits are pink boxers and yellow
bow ties just got a super
passive-aggressive email from Steve
about the bachelor party it's probably
gonna be really tacky I can't believe
you guys got vagina straws surprise
surprise
five cosmos for us thank you you make
that six actually no we're just gonna
have five just in your time that was a
$70 vagina cake the wedding is tomorrow
and I can't wait for it to be over
because I am losing my mind
[Music]
way back the sons of [ __ ] were all
right was xxx of wood yes didn't want to
step on your toes but I was starting to
wonder when you're gonna wake up these
sleepy heads
you're getting married today right here
you go
get your coffee we got a big schedule
ahead
[Music]
maid of honors here do not look at my
hair hypercard from Allah so I kind of
love number something I can't find my
suspenders somebody needs to go on to
the rental car look for the keys we
can't find the keys right now I need
help I'm sorry okay you know what you're
doing
[Music]
[Applause]
three
did the maid of honor like wake up five
minutes before this wedding started and
did she even care about it
damn her arms in that dress I mean the
one in the middle is the lawyer
[Music]
you take Ella sickness and in health as
long as you both shall live I do Ella do
you take Eugene in sickness and in
health as long as you both shall live
you may kiss the groom no nella for a
really long time
Eugene you're a cool dude you took my
best [ __ ] from me if you like
[Music]
yeah single over here so so I've known
Eugene for a long time now probably
longer than any of his other friends
well we took a trip to Big Sur last year
he said Steve I met this girl and I said
what's her name and he said her name is
Ella and I said Ella that's beautiful I
mean that's what that's what the Greeks
called Greece they call it Ella's and I
was like is she the one Eugene he said
Steve
I know and I just I want to say may you
love each other more every single day I
love you you did
[Music]
that was a beautiful speech you know I
couldn't have done today without your
help
I'm not the best man
we're the best men can over here at mono
I don't know if I can do another wedding
man I'm done no way it wasn't really a
ceremony no effing way hey want to get
out of here